- My self-esteem is just real fucked up
because I, um, when I was a child,
I felt like I was never
accepted in, in, in nothing.
I was never good in school.
I could never play sports
'cause I couldn't see.
All the kids would pick
on me, push me around,
call me a sissy, call me a pussy,
beat me up.
They didn't wanna hang around with me.
My, uh, my sisters and my
brothers, they used to,
they used to pick me
'cause I was, you know,
I was, I was, I was scary, I was a pussy,
you know, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't fight back
in any way and they
would pick me and push me
and all this kind of shit.
And then to top all of that off,
Pops was jumping on mom all the time
and I was, I was the kid
in the, in the family
that never really said, I never, I never,
I was like, I've always
been the black sheep
in the family.
I mean, I'm, I'm not, dude,
I'm not the black sheep,
I'm the black, that blackest
black of the black sheep
in the family.
I mean, I mean, that's
how I've always felt.
Um, I was thinking back when
I, when I went to school,
this is where it started.
My dad, he was real
strict on going to school.
I was never, ever, ever good at school.
Not because I didn't wanna be.
I have a hard time learning.
You know, I'm not, I
don't, I'm not, I'm not,
I'm not, I don't pick
things up like other people,
so one day I had some homework
and I asked my father
to show me how to do it.
He showed me one time
and I didn't do it right.
He beat the shit outta me.
He beat the fuckin' shit outta me.
So, before that, me and my
mama were kind of close.
And they got into it, so my mom left,
so I told, I didn't have her anymore.
My mother, my mother, me and
my mother were real close.
Back then we were real close.
And there was a couple people
that I remember, let's see,
I never told my mother,
but I was kind of getting to the point
where I was, I woulda told her that,
but she end up leaving and
I never could understand
why a person, your, most
would say their daddy,
but my mother left us, you know.
So, that, that, that,
that put a hole in me
and these are the things
that are coming to matter,
I never really, really,
you know, so, but anyway,
let me go back, I'm jumpin' around.
Um, oh, the homework.
I got, I got my ass whooped so ever since
that day, I was afraid to tell anybody
I couldn't, I couldn't figure the shit out
because I feel like my
sisters and brothers
would tell me I was dumb, yeah, you dummy,
you know, you're dumb,
you're stupid and all
this kind of shit.
This is the kind of shit
that, that stuck to my,
that, that, that stuck
here in the back of my head
and where it really stuck
was down in the gut, man,
be down in the gut, that shit's down,
that's shit down there deep.
And now my age is starting to come up
and it's starting to
come up strong, you know,
and I, and I can't figure out
why I can't shake that shit.
You know, so it got my self-esteem lowered
and lowered and lowered and low.
So when I drink, I can, I can, I can act
like I'm tough and like
the shit don't bother me.
That shit hurt, dude.
This motherfucker...
He had a, he had a, he had a, he had a,
something, something for school.
He had a pickup truck and I was so,
anyway, I was, I wouldn't
never tell anybody
that I couldn't pick up in school.
So on through school,
I learned how to cheat.
I learned how to forge his name.
I was thinking back to
when I was, I was, I was
in junior high school,
I got five fuckin' Fs
on my report car.
My father would have literally, I would,
he would have put me four foot under,
but I learned how to
forge and all that shit
and I didn't think he really cared,
'cause he never went down to check on it
and I was thinkin', the
fuckin' LA school district,
they didn't give a fuck.
I mean if I had a kid and
he was gettin' all them Fs,
I would've told my parents.
They didn't give a shit.
You failin' out, they figure your family
don't give a shit,
we don't give a fuckin' shit.
So here I am, I been like
they don't give a shit,
Pops don't give a shit, Mom don't,
she don't give a shit.
My brothers and sisters,
they don't like me.
So, who I got?
All I got is me and this
fuckin' crazy ass thinking
that I got that's still
hauntin' me to this day.
I remember when I,
I got to, um, I was, I was, I was due to,
I was supposed to
graduate from high school
and I, I, I, I, I, I, you
had to pass an SAT test.
I never, ever, ever, ever, ever, ever
could pass fuckin' tests.
I've never been good at tests.
But all that stem back from when I was,
I was, I was afraid to tell the tea...
I was afraid to tell my teachers
I'm, some, I, I can't, I, I can't get it.
I just, so I would sit there,
I would just sit there and fail.
I was afraid to say I
couldn't do it, you know.
So, but it always, I'm, I'm a tell what,
so it made me feel, there's
just, there's just pain
deep down in my gut that I started gettin'
as a child from people tellin' me
you ain't shit and you ain't,
so, naturally, I'm always
tellin' myself I ain't shit.
So anyway (indistinct) to go up and back,
now I'm sittin' in my apartment
and I just, you know I just wanted
to be around some families.
I'm sitting in my room, I'm by myself,
I ain't got no friends,
I ain't got no girlfriend.
I ain't got nobody, you know.
And when, when every time, I remember,
I remember, I, I also traumatized
because my mother left me, man.
I'm traumatized.
That fuckin' bitch just fuckin' walked
and fuckin' left.
Left her fuckin' kids, man.
So we were there in the house
and my father got these
fuckin' young ass girlfriends
and they would fight with
my sisters and brothers.
She nearly young as I am.
You know, what the fuck?
So I tried to stay away from the house
as much as I could.
I was at my best buddy's
house all the time, you know,
and my Pops would tell us
to be home at 12 o'clock
and I was a sneaky motherfucker.
I would, I would, I put the, I put the,
I put the oil and we had
a sliding glass door,
I would put the, put the oil
in the sliding glass door
and push it out and sneak out at night.
If he ever caught me,
he would have fuckin' killed me.
He never caught me.
But, uh, every time he got,
every time my dad would
get home from work,
you know, I, I, I, I see other kids,
man it was, like my best,
my best friend's daddy,
that was my daddy, you know, he was cool.
One time, one time this girl was,
me and this girl were fightin', you know,
and my best friend told his
daddy and he came outside
and he was talkin' to me, you know.
I said, "I wish my dad
would talk to me like that."
It was, it was, you know, it was,
I couldn't, I couldn't,
I could never talk about,
my father, it was always,
it was always da, na,
it was, it was, he
never, he never listened.
I couldn't, I didn't have,
I didn't have no say so.
I remember I knew a guy who was a sergeant
that said, "Never break a man on the spot.
Always let your kid buck,
let your kid buck up
a little bit just so he keeps his pride."
No, Dad didn't give us,
no, you better not buck up.
You better, you better step,
he say that the goddamn sky was green,
you better sit there
and tell the whole world
that motherfucker's green.
That motherfucker's green.
You know, so we, that's, that, that, that,
that's how it was.
But I really wanted,
but I really wanted to tell him, hey, man,
help me, dude.
I'm going through some shit.
You know, and I, you my father,
Mom's done left, you Pops, man.
You, you need, you need to every,
if I was trying to tell you
that I can't do something,
you call me stupid.
Ah, you dumb.
Tellin' me, "I don't know
what's gonna become of you."
I don't know what's gonna, you know,
and people, when I first
got hooked on drugs,
I was living, I was living
with my grandmother.
I stole some money out her purse.
In fact, about that shit, I
told my grandmother the truth,
I said, "Grandma, I got a drug problem.
I took your money."
My grandmother was happy.
I don't know why she was
singin' and rejoicin'
and she say, "You told me the truth, son."
She said, "You got a problem, it's okay."
"You told the truth, I saw God."
Don't tell Dad, please don't tell Dad.
She tells Dad.
And Dad comes runnin' over to the house.
I stayed in the basement
and then he comes in the basement
and he sits down beside
me for the first time.
He didn't, he didn't yell and scream.
He said, "Goddamn it.
It's my motherfuckin' fault."
I said, "What do you mean
it's your fuckin' fault?"
"I didn't raise you right."
But I wanted to turn around and tell him,
you goddamn right it's your fuckin' fault,
but I couldn't, you know, but he said,
"Oh," he said, "Oh, it's my goddamn fault,
but you still, you still
ain't never gonna be shit."
But he's, he's tellin' my family,
he's talkin' behind my
back tellin' my family,
"A grown ass motherfuckin' man.
How in the fuck, he's still,
he ain't got a damn job,
living with his goddamn women.
He's sorry.
He ain't gonna never be nothin'."
This is his favorite, "I don't know what's
gonna become of him.
He ain't gonna never be nothin'.
He ain't gonna never be nothin.
He ain't gonna never do nothin'.
He'll never be nothin'."
So this is, this is, he's all I had
and that's all, that's
all he would tell me.
So my self-esteem is fuckin' wrecked.
It's fuckin' low as a motherfucker
and I, I, I can't,
relationships, oh, my God.
I can't stay in a relationship.
I get in a relationship.
I remember when, when,
when one of my girlfriends,
who I really liked a lot, I told her,
something we were worrying about
and I said, "Well, go ahead on and bitch,
you gonna leave any motherfuckin' way."
And she turned around
and she looked, she said,
"Why would you say that, why would you?"
And I, and I, and I,
I'm, I'm, I'm realizing
from way back then and when she said it
because when my mother left me,
all the women I've had, I've
got some pretty decent women
and they keep me as long as they,
they keep me for so
long and they, and they,
they just, and I, I usually
get hurt and start crying.
I don't give a fuck.
Get the fuck on.
I don't, bitch, get the fuck on,
I don't give a fuck what
you do. That's what I say.
But what really goes
on down here in my gut
is that fuckin' feelin' again.
I start feelin' that, just, you know,
that, that, that
loneliness, that loneliness
and that discouragement
and I start thinking
about killin' myself and oh,
this motherfucker, this
is where I was going,
this motherfucker told me one time,
"Why don't you," told his son,
"Why don't you just go
run out in the street
in front of a motherfuckin' car
so it could run your ass over,
so we ain't gotta worry
about your dumb ass no more."
He told me, his son.
How the fuck, how the fuck
can you tell your kid,
your fuckin' kid, who's, who's not,
I was, I'm not doing too
well, something's wrong.
Ask, try to find out
what the fuck is wrong.
He finds I'm in, in, that I had jokes,
"You're gonna go to a fuckin' program."
Okay, fuck a program.
Well, he took me to the goddamn,
he worked for Northrop Grumman,
that's a high class ass
motherfuckin' program.
Everybody drivin' up in (indistinct),
I went in that motherfucker,
I got kicked out.
I've been to 67, 67 drug and
alcohol treatment centers
in my lifetime.
Maybe more, it may be more.
And every time I go, I fail.
And every time I fail,
it keeps me from going back in
because I, before I
go, before I get there,
I'm already saying you're gonna fail
any motherfuckin' way.
You're gonna, that's all, that's all you,
that's all ever did.
Just like your daddy said.
But when I went, he tried to send,
he tried to send me off to college
and I couldn't pass any
of the tests good enough
to get into the school and they caught me
with a girl, so when I came home,
he said, "I spent the
money to go to school
with your dumb ass, why did you fuck up?"
So, for the first time in my life,
I said, "'Cause you told
me I wasn't gonna never
be shit, so maybe that's
why I ain't shit."
I told him like that and he looked at me.
He said, "You know I ain't
told you no fuckin' shit.
Don't you lie on me
like that," (mumbling).
Again, and I think I was,
then I was about 21 years old,
so I still couldn't, I
couldn't, I, I couldn't,
I couldn't lash and talk
back, you know, but,
these are the things that are, that are,
that are affecting me
in my life right now,
but, but, but, the, the, the main one is,
here it comes.
Me and my daughter's mother
were livin' and usin'.
We had my daughter.
They said, "Your
daughter's not coming home,
we found drugs in your system.
We're gonna take her."
That day, I fuckin' died.
I've never felt alive since that day
and I never said that and
that's the fuckin' truth.
That shit, it eat my ass up.
So, my family, they think
I'm just drinkin' and usin',
because I don't give a fuck.
Oh, that sorry son of a bitch.
Got a daughter, how could he...
They think I'm doin' that shit
'cause I don't give a fuck.
Well, now I'm hooked.
That's the only thing I know about
that I do how to suppress the,
how to suppress the pain.
For the, for the, for
the, for the, for the,
for the moment at that time anyway,
like I been sober for a few days now.
I've been sober for a many few days
and it's so fuckin'
miserable inside of me.
It's just, it's just, I don't eat as much,
I don't have no appetite
and I, I don't, I, I don't
like being around people.
I don't, you know, I got a telephone now,
I don't even want the damn phone,
I don't use the goddamn phone
and, you know, I was, I mean I was,
like I met this lady and she,
and we were suppose to
get together the other day
and she, "Oh, I couldn't
'cause I had do to this."
And I said to myself, I
deleted her from the phone.
I don't, I don't need you no goddamn,
I live here, I don't need you fuckin' way.
That's my attitude.
I don't fuckin' need you.
But, but, but, but, but,
really, really I need somebody,
you know what I'm saying.
I need somebody.
Now the fuckin' SSI, they
tell me cut me off SSI
'cause I wasn't a mental health patient.
I would have been mental health patient,
take the medication, I
didn't get me the medication.
They gave me medication,
I stopped taking it for bipolar.
They gave me it for bipolar.
You guys can probably tell I'm bipolar.
I go up and down, up and down,
up and down, my crazy ass.
But, um, I, um, all kind
of medication I take.
So, here I am, this is what,
this is what I'm thinkin',
here I go on another go around.
I'm gonna end up homeless again.
I fixin' to lose, I'm fixin' to lose
everything out my apartment
and I'm homeless livin' on
the motherfuckin' street,
be right back out here
on the motherfuckin' street
and I said I can't, I can't, I can't live
in the street no more.
I gotta figure out
something something to do.
I cannot, I can't, I cannot,
because I can't, I can't, I can't go back.
I'm just 'cause I, I,
I like my little place
and my apartment is so goddamn small
when you walk through the front door,
you fall over the back fence (laughing).
When you look at the wall on the left,
you lookin' at the wall on the right, too,
all at the same time 'cause
it's so goddamn small.
Shit, you know, but I like it
'cause it's my place and I have a key.
And that's where I can
go when I feel like,
'cause I can't, I don't
take this out, out nowhere.
You know, I grab nobody and say,
hey, man, this is how I'm feeling.
I'm feeling like committing,
I been feeling like committing
suicide lately, dude.
I mean, I knock on every door,
but that's how back I feel.
That's how fucked, that's
how fucked up inside I feel
by the things that went on in my life
that I can't, I just can't shake 'em.
I just can't shake 'em.
I ain't got nobody to talk to.
You know, thank God, I come
here and talk to my friend here
and I come, he, you just don't know how
this give me some relief of this shit
that I be going through, but you can't,
you, this, it's rough
and tough out here, boy.
You got to, you got to
have, you got to act like,
hey, man, you got to act
like back the fuck up off me.
I'm a motherfucker, you know, you can't,
you can't let nobody know
I'm hurtin', you know.
I feel like, I feel like (indistinct).
But, oh, back to, back
to my daughter, man.
They lied to me.
I gave her to my sister
and that fuckin' bitch
took her and stripped her of her name,
would not allow her to
see her mother and father
and damn near kept her away from me
as much as she possibly could.
So now she's 18 years old
and she lied to her and told her,
here's the kill, here's, here's
the, here's the real kill.
Here's the, now, this, this, this,
this is the gut crusher.
She told her that I was her uncle
and I have never, ever
told her no different.
And...
I don't, like my sister,
see, I don't, I don't,
I don't have money to contribute to her.
She's in school now.
So it's a big fuss in the family,
I hear her say, "This sorry motherfucker.
He ain't got no money for his daughter."
Well, I don't have no money for me.
You know, and, and, and I don't know
what I'm gonna do.
I don't, I don't, I don't,
I don't know what I'm gonna do,
but I just, I just feel
so, so, so, so lonely
and depressed and demoralized
and, and, and, and
low and, and, and every, I always think
the negative, you know,
like I said my partner,
he was telling me about
a lady friend of his.
I said I knew I made a joke about her
and I didn't see him anymore
and I thought he don't like me no more.
I just, I am, that's, that's,
that's how my head tells me, you know.
He don't like you.
He don't wanna be around you, you know.
And even in front of my apartment complex,
the guys like to hang out
and stand around in the front.
They think that I, I know
they think that I'm stuck up.
I just don't, I don't, I don't,
I don't, I don't socialize.
I don't, I don't stand there.
I think one time I was drunk,
but I don't stand in front of the house.
I don't stand around in front of
and I, I stood around
and got shot one day.
I don't, I don't like standin' around.
They shot me once, they
tried to kill me one day
with a .22 hand rifle or whatever.
So I don't like standin' around, but,
but that's the kill that I,
she's 18 years old,
she's in college and I never,
I never, I never have told her...
I sat there, my daughter,
I'm her father 'cause
I'm too goddamn ashamed
because I don't have anything for her
and, and I, and I, and I, and I,
I hate the fuckin' feeling, dude,
but that shit's, that just
killing me, it's fuckin'...
And on Christmas day and my sister's
got this great big fuckin' estate
and we all go over there
and I sit in a corner, you know,
I don't fuck with nobody.
And, uh, you know, oh, and,
uh, the Fourth of July,
you know, I just, I just, I just wanted
to be around some family, you know.
I said let me go,
I was gonna go over to my brother's house
where I used to live and I went over there
and he's like (mumbling)
"Don't knock on my door
and where are you going,
why you come over here?
And what you..."
I mean, he hurt my feelings
because I was like,
I'm gonna take with my family,
it's a holiday, you know.
"I'm tired from workin'."
He's groundin' and
fussin' and talkin' shit,
you know I had to check his ass.
"Hey, man, hold the fuck on.
I came by to fuckin' see you
and you fuckin' talkin' shit," (mumbling).
So, I don't, I don't, so I asked him
for a little change, you know,
man I need, change, mean, I
need a little bit of money.
"I ain't givin' you no fuckin' money.
We don't give no fuckin' money."
Dude, I'm down.
You know, I, if I, if I, if I, if I, I, I,
I had a little part-time job with this guy
and he said your family,
he said, "I met some of your family.
They so fuckin' successful.
Why don't they help you?
Why do they let you?"
When I went to work for the guy,
I was homeless and stinky.
The guy had to help me clean up.
Man, I smelled like a goddamn wet buffalo.
Oh, and when, the time
when I became homeless,
somebody stole my fuckin' car
and everything I had.
I used to kind of detail cars
and all my shit was in the car.
And I remember, I remember, uh,
I was so damn depressed,
I came down here and I just,
oh, this is where I wanted to go.
When it gets close to Father's Day,
this, listen, I gotta tell this.
Nobody knows this.
What a sorry, no good, on Father's Day,
I don't claim, I don't claim,
you know, Father's Day.
Don't call me, don't call me
and say happy Father's Day.
It ain't gonna be no happy Father's Day.
Since my daughter was
born on her birthday,
the fire department and LAPD
have to peel me off the street.
On her birthday and on Father's Day
because I get so goddamn drunk
till I fuckin' pass out.
I do it every single fuckin' year
and the cop, the LAPD said, hey, y'all,
the LAPD said, "Can we
give you a ride home?"
(laughing) I was like, "Fuck it."
They were concerned because
they were like, "Man, you
got two fifths of liquor
sittin' on the ground,
you layin' on the ground,
you done peed on yourself,
you shit on yourself
and you, you look like you been cryin',
what's goin' on?"
They were like, "What's goin' on,"
and I couldn't tell 'em.
I said, "Ah, I'm just fuckin' crazy,"
but the fact is I, I, I
that they took my daughter and I, and I,
I haven't done it anymore.
And when that really
hits, it really hits me
in the gut, I, I, I, I, pass out.
My brain, my body just
locks up and I pass out.
You know, so these, these feelings,
I suppress 'em, I suppress 'em,
'cause I don't talk, don't
talk to nobody about 'em
and anything I get into.
When I go around my
family, I just, I just,
I just...
The way I feel is I feel so
out of place, so different, so less than,
so, they're so successful
and I'm such a loser
and I think I was drunk one time
and told my brother, said,
"You and dad are so winners.
Greg, you guys are such
big time winners, you know,
and I'm just a fuckin' loser."
My brother said, "What the
fuck are you talkin' about."
I'm just a motherfuckin' loser.
I'm nothing, nothing
like you guys, you guys,
I'm just not, I'm just not, you know,
I think, and I start trying to think about
what am I good at.
I'm good at...
I've never completed a damn
thing in my life, never.
I have never, oh, when I,
when I started driving a truck,
my father, instead of
saying, oh, I'm so happy,
my son is finally doing somethin' right,
"What the fuck are you doin' with all
your goddamn money?
You need to be buyin' a fuckin' house."
Nobody never taught how to,
and this day, my age, I don't know
how to manage money.
I don't know how to go to the bank
and how to, how to do,
do, do, I just don't,
I was too afraid to ask Dad or somebody
to each me to do that.
I don't, I didn't, I didn't, and I,
he immediately, he immediately was saying,
"You ain't gonna do nothin'
with your money, any,"
I mean, he was already tellin' me,
so this is what I'm thinkin', you know,
you make all that money,
you need to buy a house.
And I said, "Well, how in the fuck?"
I said, I'm thinking a house costs,
cost a quarter of million dollars.
Where in the fuck am I gonna get
a quarter of a million dollars?
You know, I had, I had a, I was so bad,
I had a friend of mine,
we used to work at the
same, not my friend,
we had the same job, we made
the same amount of money.
He had a brand new fuckin' Nissan
and every weekend I was askin' him for $20
to put some gas in my car.
I couldn't understand what the fuck,
you got a brand new car.
You got your own place,
I'm livin' with grandma.
And you, 'cause he knew how to,
he said my, my, "My mama taught me how
to budget my..."
I don't know a fuckin'
think about a budget, dude.
I don't, I mean, and I,
I mean, and I, and I,
it's embarrassing to say
how you gonna walk up to somebody and say,
hey, man, can you show me how to budget?
I don't now how to budget.
But there's, and all this is the shit
that's fuckin' eatin' me.
It's just eatin' my ass up.
You know, and I, and I, and so,
it adds to my already low self-esteem.
Oh, my God.
I have a very low self-esteem,
but I, I, I, I like to make people laugh.
You know, I've always been, good things,
one of the good things
people have always told me,
they say, "You're funny, you could..."
Because I always, I
make jokes about things
to keep me from being....
I'm a, I'm a, I'm, not to put this,
this guy had died, Robin
Williams, that poor guy
and everybody around him that knew him,
that thought they knew Robin,
I can't believe Robin committed suicide.
No, not Robin.
Robin was the funniest person,
but I can't identify with Robin
because I, went I can,
when I really feel like bein' funny,
I can be funny as hell,
but goddamn when you talk about
what's down all up in this motherfucker,
sometimes I could take a shotgun
and hold the motherfucker to my chin
and just whoom, off with
my motherfuckin' head.
And I think, one or twice a week
that's the way I think.
And I'm pretty sure that's
how Mr. Robin was thinkin'.
But people wanna say no, no, no, no,
you don't know what's going on.
So I can identify with Robin.
Although I'm not,
because, you know, that's why,
you know I'm just like him.
Deep down in there nobody, nobody,
nobody know what's going on down in here.
Nobody knows what's going on up in here
until you tell somebody
and it's the hardest
thing in the world to do
to tell somebody I don't trust nobody,
I don't fuckin' trust no fuckin',
I don't even trust my
goddamn self (chuckling).
I don't trust nobody.
And I looked at myself.
My clothes are, you ought
to see my damn closet.
I got more shit, I got,
my closet got stacked up,
I look like, what's the name?
Judge Clampett, where Elly May
used to throw all that shit.
My closet's so stacked up
with goddamn dirty clothes,
if my mother saw that goddamn,
I got so many dirty clothes.
I haven't been to wash.
My clothes right now,
shit I take a shower,
but I take, I got, I put,
I got to, I go to, I go through
the dirty clothes hamper
and get the cleanest
dirty pair of pants, okay.
I got to, I got the
cleanest fuckin' dirty.
Only thing, when I get in the shower,
I wash my drawers because I
ain't wearing no dirty drawers.
I wash my, I wash my,
roll 'em out in the soap
and I wring 'em out and
put 'em on a hanger,
hang 'em on the line
and I put them back on.
I wear the same goddamn...
When I, when I, when I got,
when I got, when I end up homeless,
I had one pair of socks,
one, I had one pair of shoes,
one pair of socks, whatever I had on,
that's all I fuckin' had
and I said, okay, how am
I gonna figure this out.
How I'm gonna figure out how
to make all this shit last.
I said wash my shit in the street,
hide my clothes over here
and (mumbling) my family, they never knew,
they never seen me, they never
seen me really out there.
They, they, they think that I'm doin'
what I'm doin' because I'm just,
fuck my daughter, they don't,
they love me, but they
don't really like me.
They stay they distance
because like he wants to get loaded.
He don't, he don't wanna take her,
he just wants, he just
wants to be a fuckin'...
And it's hurts me because I wanna say,
I wanna get my family together
and say hey, man, I'm not, I'm not,
I'm doin' this, you know,
to be rebellious.
I'm doing this 'cause now, now I have to,
it's, it's, it's an
addiction and it's a habit.
And it's a motherfuckin' habit.
So I was standing there and
I ended up sitting up here
and I was contemplating suicide again.
I would never do it,
but I'm kind of thinking
about killin' myself. I
said, man, I wish I was dead.
I just wish sometimes, I just
wish I would just lay down
and go to sleep and never
the fuck wake up again.
And I thought about the phone number
of my friend here to come and talk
about my prob... and now I
actually feel a little better.
I feel a little better.
But, uh, I got that off my chest
and I hope, and I won't, I'm
a stop in a little while,
but I know as soon as I stop
I'm gonna think about oh, what other shit.
'Cause on the way down I was thinking
about all kind of shit I wanna talk about.
But, I, I feel better because I talked
about the real, real, real.
I tell you guys about a lot of stories
and sometimes I exaggerate,
sometimes I don't tell 'em all.
But that one I just told you
about my gut, that, that, that's real.
That's fuckin' real.
That shit is killin' me.
I mean, that fuckin' shit is, is like a,
Paul said in the Bible,
he had a thorn in his side.
I got a thorn here, a
thorn here, a thorn there,
a thorn there.
You know, so, you know, that,
that's, that's how it went
and, um, thanks for listeners.
You guys really helped me out.
Okay, we signin' out now you guys.
- [Interviewer] Y'all take care.
- [Louis] Thanks for listening.
- [Interviewer] All
right, Louis, thank you.
- [Louis] That okay?
I really, I really, really
needed to get on camera.
- [Interviewer] That was good.
- [Louis] I feel, I feel so,
well, this is true, it's
just the truth, man,
and I feel so much better, Mark.
You're a therapist out here.
You don't even, you're like a
little angel running around,
like a little white angel
runnin' around this motherfucker.
Like I said, ain't nobody gonna fuck
with you 'cause they figure
the the white motherfucker is crazy.
He gonna right here in front
of all these black boys
and he didn't even care.